now throughout the pandemic intensive
care has been a part of the nhs which
has been under the most consistent
pressure
now doctors are warning that some staff
simply don't want to come back to work
because of the huge demands being placed
on them
well doctor shonda pondlar who's an
intensive care consultant uh is also
honorary secretary of the intensive care
society joins us now
um you've described it as being a little
bit like working
in a war zone just just tell us what the
daily grind
is like at the moment for those in
intensive care
hi um good morning jane um
first of all it's we're starting
this has been going on for about 10
months now so
we've been seeing increased numbers of
patients coming in
over a variety of ages many of them in
their 40s 50s 60s
who were previously fit and well who are
incredibly sick intensive care units
across the country have been doubled in
numbers
um so the number of normal beds that
they had a year ago
they've been running it twice that for
several months
of course we don't have those kind of
staffing available
so we've had to redeploy staff from
other areas and current staff
have been working extras when there's
meant to be
resting or when they're meant to be on
holiday
um and on top of that we've seen a
significant rise
in the number of people being off sick
and a lot of that is just due to the
pressure of the work
because often these staff won't
necessarily be intensive care staff so
they're
they're being put in in an environment
which is a great deal more stressful
than they're used to
at a time when it's even more stressful
than it normally would be
absolutely and what we're also finding
is that many intensive care units
um there are a lot of patients turning
up that would normally be treated on
intensive care but are having the same
treatments
outside of intensive care and the
respiratory doctors and the acute
physicians
are all having to look after those
patients so the nurses in those areas
who are having to be trained up to use
them in very very
rapid time
uh understandably uh feeling
under pressure um so across the country
we're seeing the staff
are getting to the point now where
they're really thinking we can't how
much longer do we have to do this for
what
what kind of stuff are you having to do
for patients because
at the end of their lives they'd
obviously hope to have their loved ones
around them and that's just not possible
because of covert
absolutely so what normally happens is
to
their families have been visiting
patients and i
and if we feel that they are
aren't likely to survive we will call
the fa we will
call the families in go and sit down
chat to them make sure that they
have a nursing staff that they may well
have become quite friendly with
um to to comfort them as well and
then they can go in and sit with their
loved one and watch them pass away now
this time round the last thing many
families will remember
is seeing their loved one being bundled
away in the back of an ambulance
and us giving
daily updates on what's going on but the
interventions we do on intensive care
are very
challenging to actually visualize and so
often
we find ourselves having to have that
conversation at the
end of life um quite often places will
allow families to come in at that point
but again if a family is having to
isolate then
that's not a viable option and many of
them live
too remote to be able to do that that
we find ourselves taking the place of
those families and
ensuring the the patient's
wishes regarding uh how they pass away
uh followed so that's
in terms of just actually physically
being there maybe playing music
maybe just just them knowing that
they're not alone
yes i've had colleagues taking beer for
example
i've had colleagues play guitar
whatever we can do that is within our
capacity we will we will do
often it's putting the family on on
facetime
and allowing them to be able to converse
or even just look at the patient passing
away in the hope that that gives some
sort of a demonstrated love for them
i mean having to break the news to a
family that their loved one
is about to pass away must be absolutely
the hardest and worst part of your job
how many times a day are you having to
do it
well i think normally we'd probably do
it maybe once a day
and over the last few months maybe
anywhere up to two three times a day
i mean and it becomes emotion it's very
emotionally draining
for everyone involved it's very
difficult to keep
doing that i mean the families
obviously must express their gratitude
do you feel
their gratitude from them and the rest
of the population for what you guys are
are doing it's truly extraordinary
i i am yes i think the the families
definitely
uh know and and do thank us afterwards
um again sometimes it's very hard to
understand what's happening
so sometimes it can be very frustrating
for for both sides
and the public as well you know on the
whole they they do show
gratitude for what's going on and they
do
um honor our requests to stay away from
the hospital
first of all because we don't we don't
um want to encourage people who've been
isolating to
spread the disease but um
you know it's very frustrating for them
to not be able to visit for example
and i know a lot of families really
struggle with that and i'm very grateful
that they
follow the rules and just briefly how do
you
cope how do you decompress who do you go
to
at the end of a horrific day
well it's it's always your family i find
it very difficult to decompress but um
you know i've got three children and my
wife
spends most of her time when she's not
operating she's a surgeon
um basically uh
corralling my children into quiet areas
to allow me a bit of time um but they're
all being home schooled at the moment
yeah i watched the football or you know
i follow manchester united
um i've got a guitar that i'd play very
badly
um but it's those kind of things it's
the small things that you take comfort
in
you know play with your children build
lego with them watch films
but the difference between i know you
described i've
described as being in a war zone
occasionally it's it's different to
being in a war zone
because in a war zone you go away for
several months and then you come back
and you you anticipate prolonged periods
of peace
in this you go to a very highly stressed
environment where you're making
decisions that have a repercussions if
you get them wrong
for 12 15 hours and then you come home
where that stimulation isn't there and
it's very hard to turn on turn off
and i think a lot of my colleagues that
we're seeing
really struggle with that kind of
intermittent overload
and then come home again doctor
shondapan
we're gonna have to leave there i'm
afraid but we're really grateful for you
for coming on
this morning and talking to us and
indeed grateful for all that you and
your colleagues are doing for so many
families
thanks a lot